Well,
hello, how are you? Sali Jaramillo greets you
with the brief information for today, Monday
, March 1st. The school transport
will look different now, since
some rules were modified to give the
green light to return to school, they will only
have 50% capacity, which implies
around  of 28 students in each one in
addition the children will be located in a
different way to respect
social distancing they will be
disinfected regularly after each use
there will be extra hand sanitizer and
masks everyone must wear
their masks
if you are a parent and you are
wearing your  children to school remember
that there will be new rules that's right
elementary students will be assigned
to different doors and
hallways students traveling on
school buses will be the last to enter
the establishment parents or adults
in charge of minors will not be able to wait for
them inside  the institution we
review the school plan back to
school and  On March 22,
grades 6, 9, and 12 will begin under a hybrid model,
on April 6, grades 7, 8,
10, and 11 will also begin on April 6. It is
expected that students will already take
classes in person on the 5
days of  last week, however, the cis
jesse clarified that he will continue with the option
of distance education for
full time for parents who so
wish
and now we move on with the
weather forecast, a sunny day with
temperatures close to normal is expected, the
maximum will be in  60 degrees by
Wednesday night a chance of
rain and then temperatures in the
70s have a good day choto y sal y
jaramillo and this was great in Spanish
[Music]